Bueno pues exactamente aquí el ambiente
está un poquito más decaído ha ido
decayendo con el aumento con el avance
de ese conteo entonces aquí algunos han
empezado incluso a irse pero también han
aprovechado para agradecer a bolsonaro
el presidente actual sus cuatro años sus
cuatro años de gobierno vamos a ver cómo
se siente por aquí la gente
Cómo equivoqué si estás sintiendo Con
este resultado de la elección Buenas
noches
Bueno lo que me siento es revoltado
[Música]
algo
brasilero lo que está en la cara del
brasileño no es una victoria Y eso es
terrible para nosotros no
está esperando aquí como un nuevo
gobierno qué esperas tú con el nuevo
gobierno de Lula es terrible porque los
números hablan por sí solos
nosotros tenemos a Venezuela Cuba ahora
Argentina con casos de inflación
corrupción y no va a ser diferente aquí
en Brasil esperamos realmente que el
presidente
judicialice todo eso que active el
artículo 142 de la Constitución Federal
y que haga valer la pena que lo que
están haciendo los brasileños hoy
Bueno pues como Ven aquí la gente está
un poco decepcionada y algunos han dicho
que van a respetar el resultado tal y
como ha sido pero otros han dicho que no
confían en este resultado y sobre todo
que no confían en el tribunal superior
electoral y han aprovechado para
insultar desde la tarima de aquí atrás a
el presidente del tribunal superior
electoral Alexander Alexander Morales
sin embargo
han dicho que son muchos que la
diferencia es muy corta los que han
votado por bolsonaros son 57 millones
entonces que van a estar presentes
durante el gobierno de Lula y que no se
les va a poder olvidar a ellos